I I tell you this all the time but like
you are truly like an anomaly in terms
of like
Instagram you're like the Andrew Tata
hip-hop in terms of just them trying to
cancel you on social media I'm not
saying like the things you'd be saying
like bro you get a new Instagram I feel
like every four weeks there's a new page
they delete your [ __ ] I don't even need
it I'll be out selling there I don't
even need it it's just crazy that you
don't even have like a like a Instagram
page to promote your music and you're
still out streaming everybody you still
have the anticipation and I can do a
tour and you're selling out your whole
tour yeah with no pay this
motherfucker's got holes it's like you
just have Twitter [ __ ] this [ __ ] just be
empty baby with that being said since
they keep deleting your pages have you
thought about posting less naked
crackheads on your story no no no that's
what I do I like I like the you know
crackhead culture you know I mean it's
great I love cracker culture too those
are people that I come from those are my
people yeah you know what I mean so now
I'll be posting them I'll be bigging
them up one time I posted this dude
he's with this crackhead this is a black
dude some dude with dreads or something
like a little you know all these [ __ ]
got dreads now but uh I don't know
I don't know maybe that was Reverse
Racism on myself but I don't know
this [ __ ] uh was doing something with
some white lady or something I don't
know but it was funny to me so I posted
it and he seen me in the street and he
was like yo that's my lady you can't be
posting me I was like [ __ ] if you don't
get the [ __ ] wait the crackhead saw you
yeah I think he was a crackhead I was at
like Smashburger or something eating a
hamburger [ __ ] was like yo man you
posted me and my girl I was like man I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't I don't really
care you know you got the good crack
post all that the [ __ ] post but it's the
thing though man I post jokes about
myself too so just because I joke on you
know I mean I don't like you people oh
no you're you're very good at
self-deprecating humor yeah they be
taking that [ __ ] too seriously like
you'll repost somebody who like posts
like one of the like 11 people who
people say you look like like Don
Cheadle by the way Shadow's a guy from
Yahoo who like called Don Cheadle he
definitely called Don Cheadle out Don
Cheadle look I talked to Don Cheadle he
said he's not gonna kick that dude in
the dick
he said he said hey my favorite rapper
Freddie Gibbs I'm not sure if he was in
on the joke or not Don ain't like that
he was like he was like what he said I
was gonna kick him in the dick you know
what I'm saying but he was like you know
what I kept my cool cause I'm working on
the movie and I don't want to hit nobody
yeah no it's it's but is it frustrating
to not have an like I mean you have an
IG
now you do I got a couple ones
um but like your official pay you don't
have you don't have an official page
anymore like no because I think you got
it back for a little bit though right I
did when I signed Warner they tried to
make this little Freddie Gibbs official
I got that [ __ ] took too
so if you get it back do you think we
could just only let Lambo post on it so
they don't take it down what's the fun
in it then you have the other one for
all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't I mean I guess it's I mean it's
been I guess as we've seen it it's
proven that I don't [ __ ] mean you
don't need it this is true I don't even
[ __ ] need it at this point [ __ ] like
what is it what the [ __ ] is uh
Zuckerberg and metal gonna the [ __ ]
gonna do to me this is true they can't
stop the music the [ __ ] coming out and
if they stop me I'll just make another
one my fans be making my Instagram page
you know that I didn't know that they'd
be making them for me like let's go to
get shut down oh I got a new one for you
right here that's the password here's
the email I'll be like all right thanks
maybe making them shits for a [ __ ] so
I'll be like do you remember like this
specific thing that uh got your official
page taken down what was I feel like
yeah a year and a half ago yeah it was a
video of this uh African dude in an
African village
and like this girl or titties had
stretched out and his eyes stretched out
and the nipple in the eyeball met and
then it was like no more page for
Freddie Gibbs it was a wrap [ __ ] yeah it
was like nah I'm ready you can't be
doing that [ __ ] man you know what I'm
saying like
it ain't looking good for you and I was
like damn that's [ __ ] up you know what
I'm saying but uh
you know I was kind of mad at first but
I ain't really tripping you're popping
up with a new page every year I probably
I'll just be on there to look at girls
anyway yeah that's what I really look at
it for I don't care about promotional
music it's a nice comedic outlet for you
though yeah it is cool that's what I
liked about it I invented that [ __ ] on
the story not everybody's doing that
[ __ ] on the story though you know but I
created that lane you know